Hi! We're excited to share Starlight today —
a documentation theme and website builder
from the team at Astro.
It takes time to make a high
performance, accessible website
that your users find easy to navigate,
but Starlight aims to make that easy for you.
Bring your content in
Markdown, MDX or Markdoc format
and we'll make it possible
to get started in minutes.
Let's take a look at what's included.
We've got color theming — dark and light mode —
full internationalization support —
change languages and see the UI change with it,
so just bring your multilingual content,
Starlight takes care of the rest.
Site search is crucial for
a documentation website:
users need to be able to find
what they're looking for.
With Starlight, it's built in.
Deploy your site, search for what
you're looking for, and find it.
Built-in components as well as bringing your
own components is all supported.
Use components from React, Preact,
Svelte, Vue, Solid, Lit, and Alpine.
Thanks to being built on Astro,
Starlight supports all of this.
If you need to customize the theme,
we have a color theme editor
to help you get started.
Try some random values for inspiration,
pick one of our built-in themes,
or adjust to match your brand colors.
When you're ready,
copy some code into your
project and you're good to go.
We're really excited to share Starlight with you.
We’ve worked hard to make
this a high performance,
accessible solution for your docs,
so whether you need small site for
your next weekend project
or are documenting a
mature product for your customers,
we hope you give Starlight a try.